- [Kelly] Well, meet everybody.
I don't know if you've met everyone yet.
- Hey, how are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- Pleasure to meet you all.
- I love your G clef on your neck.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I know, I
noticed that you coming in.
I was like, alright, alright.
- A little tattoo action.
- But Congratulations though.
You just got married .
That's amazing.
- [D Smoke] I did.
[applause]
- [Kelly] And I
I hear that I met your wife.
- [D Smoke] You did meet my wife.
- So how do I know your wife?
- She was on your show
some years ago.
She was also,
she told me that
you had asked her about one of her hobbies
and it was DDR.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
Oh yeah.
- [D Smoke] That's my wife, yes.
- With the red hair.
- Do you want to know why I remember her?
My assistant does hair like,
she has like blue or red or orange.
She does that with her hair
and that's why she reminded me of Tricia.
Oh my gosh.
It's amazing
And random.
What a small world.
- [D Smoke] Right exactly. Right?
- [Kelly] That's so random.
So you rap in English and Spanish.
So when did you learn Spanish?
- I started learning Spanish as a kid.
My family went on vacation
and I was like, oh,
Buenos días, ¿Cómo Estás?
And I thought I was the man,
cause I had two phrases,
but I,
I went to a middle school
where all my friends were bilingual.
You know, I was one of a
couple black students in a class
that was primarily Latino.
And
- I like you say Latino,
Latino.
Very sexy.
- And then, so I told myself,
I would learn,
I started off learning one word a day
that wasn't getting me anywhere.
(laughing)
And so,
but
I studied Spanish 1 2 and 3 in high school
then went on to major in
Spanish literature and in college.
So most people in that major were like...
- Yeah.
- Beautiful Experience.